you know what happened Miami I remember
because I had a job here I know where
you were in Miami because you were
performing there and you were like oh we
were probably we should go eat Western
yeah yeah she lives out here yeah yeah
and you guys dissed me
no I think I think we did we've probably
said [ __ ]
alright cried for seven days about it
let's be real but so now what happened
to the gate you had a guy you don't know
what I get sad about that is true what
do you get set up everything
I can't I get sad about my life what
parts of your life are you saddest about
right now well he's got way dark tell me
I should say it in Korean yes because
they don't know Korea and we keep in a
code word everything you say I swear to
God all understand say to me okay
900 manga cuckoo so 1j um
one month ago I didn't know that I know
I'm sad too hey do you understand I
think I got so I think we all passed
away yeah I'm sorry I don't know who but
I didn't know that how Oh heart attack
oh my god yeah oh man so can I tell him
what you said she's probably yeah yeah
yeah
I have to tell them what you said okay
tell no one
yeah her mailman got sick you know her
mom her mom her mom died a month ago
yeah she had a heart attack
wow I don't even know how you're up and
about I did a comedy show the day I
found out did you feel like you had then
I recorded a podcast and I was crying on
it yeah so how did you I mean who called
you my little brother oh the one you met
I love San Francisco he's a warlock yeah
yeah his her little brothers like a
little scientific warlock yeah I really
I really want to be with him he wanted
him on like this podcast we should have
him we should have him he's that he's
magical where did your mom live were you
guys like a really close-knit family in
Chicago well here's the I mean you want
to get it I mean I'm gonna have to ask
you some questions is that okay yeah you
guys weren't in good communication
though right from when I from what you
told me I think a couple years ago maybe
right like you don't you had resentment
toward them yeah and so there wasn't
there wasn't communication my memories
of her are more fond when I was little
yes yeah yeah yeah you know because I
didn't really spend much time with her
later in life yeah
were they probably like my parents we're
a little weirded out by your choices in
life
correct maybe yeah I don't know I mean
what was the disconnect then I mean if
you if growing up you guys were super
close or you had fond memories of her
and then maybe not everything was fond
you sure I mean you know yeah I mean I
have yeah I mean I have my my dad used
to beat the [ __ ] out of me with a
[ __ ] baseball bat and [ __ ] like that
right clubs and my dad was a [ __ ]
terror but there were little gaps of you
know can get him back while he's still
alive I can't get my mom back anymore
mm-hmm yeah yeah sorry you know yeah
yeah I sent her a letter through my you
know I worked out
dolphintherapy and my therapist told me
to write a letter and I wrote both of my
parents a letter and they sent it for ya
like this was like two years ago I sent
it oh my god
yeah so when was the last time you
talked to your mom before she passed um
I don't know maybe a couple months so
when you sent that letter was there like
a reconciliation or some type of like
closure between like the both of you
guys I don't know what happened like in
your past he makes it seem like maybe it
was not an easy upbringing but was there
when you sent the letter was there some
type of like oh we understand you now
and we got it or they said that to me
mm-hmm no my mom was like really
oblivious mm-hmm like her response to my
letter cuz like in my letter my
therapist told me to write like what you
did to me how it made me feel what I
want you to do about it
yeah and how it's affected my life now
and my letter had four parts to it and I
wrote that and you know just I just
explained like mm-hmm all the things
that why I was hurt and you know all the
pain that she had like brought into my
life and you know
and she just like wrote a check for $100
and sent it and was like was like you
know she's just like oh nice to hear
from you yeah it's so Korean yeah and
the funeral was so Korean because you
know my parents were missionaries so so
everybody from the church was there who
I grew up with yeah and I saw you know
John Lee's parents and John Lee's mom
was always such a [ __ ]
Yeah right there's a million John Lee so
nobody will know who I'm talking was an
only child and he lived in a [ __ ]
mansion compared to everybody else
everybody else was a poor missionary
living for kids in a bedroom and then
railroad style another bedroom with four
kids yeah but John Lee had the [ __ ]
life he had a rainbow painted in his
bedroom wall we were like like John
Lee's parents are like white yeah like
they like give him stuff yeah don't just
shove him in a corner and say shut up
you know stop bothering me you little
piece of [ __ ] yeah so so I saw John
Lee's mom and she's Johnny's mom it's
always like really she's always like put
together like she only wanted one kid
racist Ray's a doctor so so everybody
came up to me and you know it's crazy
how everybody looks the same
yeah I'm like I haven't seen these
people in 20 years and they look exactly
the same and I know exactly who they are
do they did most of them probably know
what you do know what no they do well
you know what [ __ ] do and they don't
say [ __ ]
no they ain't say [ __ ] what they say
well first of all cuz I was decked out
right how are you doing yeah I was
wearing a tight black dress Gilligan it
black heels and I
a black veil all perfect my sister said
I look like a young widow Korean
missionary comes up to me and they go oh
she's from Hollywood
oh yeah no but I caused so much problems
for myself at my mom's funeral why
because of what I posted on Facebook
what did you post on Facebook and I
pissed off my entire family I just wrote
something nice about my mom I thought it
was nice what'd you say right I said I
said my mom passed away today she had a
heart attack it was sudden and I said
she always liked to go to casinos Joey
spent her time between casinos and
church until she got kicked out of
church and she banned herself from every
casino they are very like she was in
Gamblers Anonymous yeah but you don't
ever say that out loud in like amongst
like other you're not supposed to like
put out other people's business right
especially in a like you know I went to
rehabs and stuff in high school and
stuff and my none of my cousins and
aunts cuz I have 28 first cuz nobody
knew it's because they just had they
hide it it's all about hiding so what
was the response lifestyle I'm all about
stripping the shame from everything and
just talking about anything on stage job
is that's what that's what I do not know
but but you know they're all still very
conservative and everybody got pissed
off at me and when I went home my dad
was like so your sister's the only one
who's gonna do the eulogy
and I was like are you kidding me I
can't even get a spot at my mom's you
should have called me I would call yo
you would have called John Lee's mom
yeah yeah right a woman Matt Matt Blake
my agent would have yeah we're hip-hop
getting Esther I got I got cancelled
from the eulogy oh my god and my dad
like made up this lie and was like they
only allow one person at a eulogy they
do and I'm like that is such a lie
because I've been to funerals like 25
people's yeah yeah you know they usually
say does anybody yeah exactly something
yeah I'm like I'll just storm the stage
then [ __ ] yeah whoa did you know
I had to convince them it was a struggle
but my friend Grace Park came over and
she for me there's also fifty other
great the Hawaii five-o brass part no no
it doesn't matter don't say her name
why five-o Grace Park this is some asian
chick so I went on periscope and I
narrowed down oh my wait wait wait you
want periscope at your mom's funeral no
no no I don't think my hotel stupid mom
what still the same day but I'm just
like working through this like
struggling to figure out like hey what
jokes are appropriate to say at a eulogy
hey Bobby that's great yeah maybe that's
good advice okay well you knew my mom
yeah you would know that she would want
jokes at her funeral okay my mom I get
my personality from my mom
yeah and it's probably why we like butt
heads and didn't get along yeah because
I just reminded her of her but like 2.0
version
and like without the FOB accent you know
so so I went through my whole set list
what through my yard yeah so Greece Park
was ignore take that one out
don't don't say anything don't say
anything with sex or you know cleaned it
up like this was like a TV clean house
yeah yeah yeah right tonight shows that
balance that okay I went to my dad's
house and I said can I do a dress
rehearsal oh yeah oh it's just to get
there oh you mean just to get their
approval you don't understand the
culture of my of my family I get it yeah
no you don't get it I do get it you're
saying whoa well I'm just saying whoa
for the audience for makeup yeah right
I would screen test myself my dad was
making jokes my dad goes oh you know I
think it's good she died because she was
always complaining about body pains you
know cuz she had arthritis and diabetes
so yeah yeah yeah but how many brothers
and sisters are there three brothers and
one sister and they were all there
obviously yeah
everyone just devastated yep
because I know that I know that I know
that your brother the one that I met
with the Warlock there's something
magical about him he's like from a
different like he's from Doctor Strange
like he can do the laser and yeah you
ever met him you don't know he has a
devil [ __ ] a ring thing in the world I
necklace and then the Cape yeah and so
um but what I'm saying is that he didn't
have a relationship right right with
them either right exactly remember that
yeah I do remember that's why I just
said it
[Laughter]
and so I mean did all the kids have that
kind of relationship with their parents
at that point no no when you have five
kids you have different relationships
with your kids okay yeah I mean this is
the way you just talk to me I just don't
like when people talk to me like where
do you fall are you I'm sorry you're
scolding me and like that's fine I don't
know where do a hard time okay can you
see it a different way though let's
rewind yeah well why did you say in a
different way when you have five kids
one I think when you have five kids
that's better so much better you treat
them differently I think you think so
from California all right so so some of
your some of your siblings work the had
a communication that you didn't have
yeah where do you fall on the
second-oldest okay but my parents never
wanted a girl I don't know if your
parents were cool with you being a girl
no my mom definitely wanted boys but it
turns out I have a six-foot-tall sister
who is like basically like we both look
like linebackers so she was fine with it
and she put as always like in sports and
stuff so that was her way of coping with
having girls so you're not like a frail
little girl you could take care of
yourself yeah and beat up your boyfriend
if he doesn't take care of you wings I
say angry but our mom died
[Music]